bringing mirth to the world of pro
football it's Dan hanus what's the poop
fella what's up Dave how are you how are
we he's a Jets fan that's why I said he
doesn't know what it's like to uh to be
victorious in pro football I was born 11
years after Super Bowl 3 and this
conversation and and law makes a good
point as an Eagles fan you remember the
good old Andy Reid days where you the
mix I'm also a Knicks fan and I remember
the 90s and into the 2000s where you
were in the mix every year at a certain
point like if I'm a Knicks fan give me
the ring uh uh that would be great but I
also now miss just being relevant as a
Jets fan give me one title I'm in that
give me one title before I die I want to
see a Super Bowl with my dad that's what
I'm looking for at this point it's all a
matter of perspective yeah I hear you
but you know your jets the first order
of business is uh who's going to be
their quarter back in 2017 and I guess
we now have our answer that it's Josh
Macau I've been having this conversation
over the last last several weeks here
Jay Cutler and Colin Kaepernick whatever
whatever knocks whatever imperfections
they respectively have Josh maau signing
him and saying this is our starter is an
announcement to the fan base we are not
in contention for the Super Bowl this
year correct well yeah but it's I don't
understand why that would be a bad thing
Tom Brady's in the division They just
won a Super Bowl I spent an entire uh
season on our podcast talking about what
I thought was going to be hashtag
gradual clined for Brady in his age 39
season and then he played better than
ever so at this point I think here's the
thing D I think the Jets are having a
sneaky okay offseason oh jeez because
stay with me here because they're team
tank they're little they're in a little
like scam for Sam mode which I'm okay
with but beyond that uh they haven't
like doled out a ton of money to get uh
Mike Glennon or Russell Okun they're
they're saving money they're jettison
the older guys that aren't a part of the
future and they got Josh maccau clearly
a move hey we need a guy to start four
to six games before breaking his
clavicle and then you bring in Christian
Hackenberg you you make he probably
sucks sorry law I mean come on yeah what
about
that but we don't know until we see him
wait hus is on the list right yeah hus
is on the list I think all of ATL is on
the list can I tell you something that
makes me courageous yeah what do you got
uhoh I am one of the very few who stood
with you and I have not been padded on
the back for that law I said Christian
hackenberg's going to make it in the NFL
now I have egg on my face but I want for
the record I I I said it and I want it
why do you have egg on your face well I
so far I mean the reports coming out of
Jets camp ain't good yeah but do you
believe the reports coming out it's the
new the New York media Market I mean
they they they're trying to sell papers
and magazines like that's what they want
to do they've said that they brought in
Josh Macau and hackenberg's going to
compete for the starting job like I I
know that it's wo is me Jet fan but give
it a shot no I will and that's why back
to my point that it has been a bad
offseason I think they're making sound
decisions saying we're not close to
competing right now uh Brady's not old
and we we got a lot of P let's figure
things out and that starts with getting
Hackenberg maybe 10 starts next year I
spoke with uh with your colleague from
around the NFL Greg Rosenthal uh he sits
in the throne the Throne of ease as a
New England Patriots fan as does Chris
Brockman I mean I it really is I you
know I I said already I'm a Steelers fan
it makes it really pains me legitimately
to sit in the same seat that Browns fans
have you know people who like to talk
about a rivalry hey the brown brown
Steelers big rivalry not really when one
team always beats the other in a game of
significance it's not a rivalry it pains
me to say the Pittsburgh Steelers are
owned by the New England Patriots here
in the 21st century is this really going
to continue you now for the next few
years has any team has a a defending
Super Bowl champ to your recollection
ever also then won free agency yeah it's
like they won the Super Bowl and now
they're they've gone into win now mode
it's kind of a scary thought right so
again why if you're unless you're the
Steelers or the Packers or a couple
other teams you can truly say contenders
Falcons if they can recover from what
happened uh it's almost a time to
regroup and really say all right how
serious do we think our our chances are
of winning this game uh the last game in
February because the Patriots they look
Unstoppable right now that's right I
kind I I I really do buy that but is
there let's try and give people hope let
okay Oakland Raiders Vegas Raiders if
they sign Marshon Lynch are they a
realistic uh foe that could knock off
the Patriots and get to the Super Bowl I
think so the biggest disappointment of
the entire 2016 season for me besides
Ryan Fitzpatrick was uh Derek Carr's
week 16 uh injury because it was there
that was that messed up the entire AFC
playoffs because if the Raiders were in
the mix and they had the Patriots I
don't know who gets HomeField Advantage
but the whole AFC playoffs is different
I thought
the I I do yes I think that's an
interesting conversation I love playing
the wh if game if Derek Carr doesn't get
hurt what how did the AFC playoff shake
out the Raiders hold on and win the West
so they would be the two seed the Chiefs
presumably would have beaten the Texans
down in Houston so the Chiefs would have
played in New England in the divisional
round the Raiders would have hosted the
Steelers for an alltime divisional show
what a game that would have been oh what
a beauty isn't it a bummer it still
winds up does so let's say the Raiders
take care of business in Oakland they
beat the Steelers then they go to
Foxboro is there any reason to think the
Raiders with Derek Carr and AOW roster
would have would would have had what it
takes to go up there and knock them off
the Texans almost had what it took to
knock them off should won that game but
you know they're the Texans they had who
they had a quarterback I mean nobody's
worried about the Chiefs in the playoffs
Andy Reid is a track record sorry law
have you ever seen something like this
like if you if you read read the papers
in New England they liken it to the 2007
off season where they knew they had a
really special team a chance that could
do something great and they just loaded
up and that's kind of what they're doing
now this offseason also do you buy the
six to seven years more of Tom Brady
that Bob Craft said the other day that
seems a little that's almost become like
uh a Trope of the off season like
veteran Star Quarterback X believes
he'll play until he's close to 50
Brady's the one guy where you you have
to be like Drew Brees just came out and
said it this week right right right uh
Brady's the one guy where you think to
yourself gez that could possibly happen
but I would think ultimately what
probably two or three years at Max right
I mean I babe tell me please it's just
two or three more years you know Tom
Brady like most people in the world of
pro football hangs on my every word and
I did when I saw the news that he
intended to play another six or seven
years I did on Twitter start to type LOL
and then I stopped myself realizing I
don't want to contribute first of all if
anybody's going to do it it's going to
be Tom Brady and he's not just going to
play for six or seven years he's going
to play well and it's going to make me
sick and I don't want to contribute to
giving him to he loves the chip on his
shoulder he wants he's Michael Jordan or
all the most accomplished athletes in
sports always have a chip on their
shoulder I didn't like the disrespect I
got so I'm not going to I'm not going to
provide that for it's the last one left
I mean what else can you put on his
plate in terms of or put on his
shoulders a chip the last one is you're
too
old now he's trying to take that down I
mean is this really what's going to
happen though is this really going to be
again with the Patriots I thought they
were done four years ago why when the
Giants beat them didn't you think that's
it all right well that was that's a
shame I feel bad for Tom Brady that this
is how he has to go out go out his
supermodel wife is weeping now it was
really h a few years ago when they got
blasted by the Chiefs and belich had to
actually answer a question post game if
he's going to re-evaluate the
quarterback position I don't think
they've lost since then I remember it
feels like they haven't lost since
Brockman how about how about this like
the idea of uh the Brady declining a
little bit this upcoming season becomes
kind of like a bottom top 10 passer like
seven eight nine sure and then the garoo
Situation's up again Brady's turning 42
before the season starts do you really
do you start to think then or 41 uh if
maybe you go with Jimmy you know what
I've always said I've always said he
ends up being the starting quarterback
for the Rams he finishes his career out
here in Los Angeles because that's where
everyone ends up anyway when you have
the star power of Jazelle and Tom and
why not play the last three years of his
career if he wants to play till he's 46
47 years old why not come out here jar
Goff is clearly not the guy and they
going to have a brand new stadium that
you're going to have to sell psls and
expensive season tickets for why not
have Tom Brady be the Marquee attraction
oh no there's a better answer to to who
should be the LA Rams quarterback you
ready for a good tease I'll tell it to
you and Dan hanus we'll debate this when
we come back
Dave damashek filling in seated to my
immediate right the host of the around
the NFL podcast go to nfl.com read Dan
hano's fine Pages the end around his
specialty mirth the subject pro football
um hey also speaking of subjects we're
talking about NFL quarterbacks but also
as we went to break the other subject
was ordering brunch bad news update on
that uh breakfast is over can't get
can't get the eggs I wanted I can't get
an egg they can't whip me up an egg of
any kind even a hardboiled egg
disappointment they have hard boiled
eggs what's your meal Power Rankings
breakfast lunch
dinner wow that's I didn't expect to get
hit with uh with that I'm the one
supposed to be doing the hard-hitting
questions here Dan Hano sorry about that
I'm going dinner you know I mean we can
put we can be cute about it we can talk
about breakfast meats and bacon and bone
in hand
and how cheesy eggs are delicious but at
the end and hash browns are Divine but
at the end of the day you know where do
you get your dinner at the end of the
day I'm taking dinner where do you get a
steak how about you right yeah well you
could get steak and egg still I'm going
a little cute with that steak and eggs
everybody's got to calm down with the
steak and eggs yeah it's not it's not
high it's not high quality beef yeah
exactly um reverse order dinner lunch
breakfast what's the best egg
preparation Dan
hanus I'll go with uh
over
easy that's a fine answer but it was a
trick question I do the Shey awards at
the end of every calendar year I award
uh you know for all manner of categories
and that's one the changes egg
preparation is not a consistent answer
it it depends on where I'm at in my life
some years it's a hardboiled egg you
happen to be correct in this case though
it's the OV easy one although poach can
be delicious if you're a fancy pants
like me soft boiled one two I mean wow
that makes you a fancy pants as well you
ever get a brazed egg that's very nice I
don't what that means I'm an American
I'm a man of the people I like my eggs
scrambled you know what that says to me
that says to me that you have low
self-esteem scrambled it's a pedestrian
Choice isn't it anywh who you know what
we've talked enough about food I'd like
to get in a lunch order before we're all
done here because I think when the clock
strikes High Noon they show me the door
and they say we're not getting you
anything um so we're talking about NFL
quarterbacks here with around the NFLs
Dan hanzus and as I promised in the last
segment the correct answer for who
should be the LA Rams quarterback has
two answers it's either Jay Cutler or
Colin Kaepernick either way you need to
make this move now I don't buy
necessarily the LA Sports Fan requires
splashy stuff to happen however The
Stereotype that they like winners is
true as it is also true in any other
sports Town people like when their teams
win that's what makes people attend
games Jared gol is not going to do that
in 2017 he is not going to be winning
games for the ram Fair that's ridiculous
his head coach is Jeff fiser the
offensive coordinator can you name who
it was last year it's a guy who had no
pedigree exactly I mean let's give the
kid a shot I know he looked bad last
year I know he looked terrible and to be
honest I don't know if you heard the
news that the Rams are the All or
Nothing team on Amazon I did just see
that yes I mean am I jumping up and down
excitement about that would Colin
Kaepernick or Jay Cutler add some juice
for that show yeah but let's not give up
on Jared go he's like 22 years old you
don't think here's the thing with uh
Colin Kaepernick and Jay Cutler and
obviously they have wildly different
skill sets with what they would bring to
a team flawed as they both are Jay
Cutler and Colin Kaepernick are both
still in the top 32 human beings on the
face of the planet Earth that play
quarterback right what what is the what
is the hold out on either one of these
guys with some of the very specious
options that are currently going to be
starting uh in 2017 well you've talked
about this for years Dave how it's
surprising that there aren't more but
it's a little more depressing than that
because there's only like 20 guys that
can actually play the position at at a
proficient level and then Cutler and
Kaepernick are in that back half of this
30 where or the back 10 of this 30 where
yeah they could lead a team and they
could have their moments but not really
good at this stage do you think Cutler
and Kaepernick in 2017 are winning 10
games for a team I know that this is
simplistic to say this but I'm going to
say it anyway Colin Kaepernick was a
throw he was one foot he he came up one
foot short of winning a Super Bowl if he
elevates that ball a little bit more to
Michael Crabtree they defeat the Ravens
they're a Super Bowl champ are we having
a conversation like this then yeah but
if Ben rburg doesn't complete third and
seven to Antonio Brown in the 2010 AFC
title game and Mark Sanchez gets back on
the field and leads the Jets to an
improvable comeback win at heines field
how do you feel about Mark Sanchez
that's all whatif stuff Dave I as a Jets
fan I torture myself about that whatif
stuff but that didn't happen things life
went on things changed let me ask you
guys about you almost got me I want to
say that that was a great retort that
that gave me pause for a second but
that's a far cry that Sanchez would have
led them to vict
and then won the Super Bowl this is one
throw for Kaepernick okay I'll back off
with the Sanchez winning the Super Bowl
he's playing great in where you guys
fall though with the whole Colin
Kaepernick's not getting a job because
he knelt do do we feel like there is
just is that a rational thought and is
that a real reason when Jay Cutler who
has accomplished more in the NFL also
doesn't have a job but on the other side
of that there were also players from
pretty much all 32 teams that KN we
they're actual my my point is as I
always say is it's weird to me in a
world of actual bad guys that when when
you hear fans say I hate LeBron James or
Tom Brady they're they're just on teams
that you're you're not rooting for
they're not actual villains Colin
Kaepernick to me kind of falls into the
he's not an actual bad guy he made a
political statement how say you do you
think he's being blackballed by some
percentage of NFL teams I don't think
he's being Blackwell specifically
because of the kneel down stuff but I
think it obviously doesn't help it ALS
Al doesn't help uh and we've talked
about this a lot on your podcast you
have in our it's a big offseason
storyline he hasn't been the same player
he's not that good a player so when you
factor in the fact that he hasn't been a
real efficient quarterback uh for like
three or four years and you have this
issue that teams don't want to get
involved with and then the Mike Freeman
Bleacher Report column from a couple
weeks ago he cited an anonymous GM who
said that and I it's this the times we
live in some teams are scared off by the
possibility
that the president of the United States
tweets and attacks a team if they go and
get Kaepernick it's it's a messy
situation scuttled the usfl who cares
what his football opinion is uh period
but yes listen I think the for whatever
flaws we can point out about uh about
these two guys these high-profile QBs if
you're the Jacksonville Jaguars so we
can take it off the ram shoulders if
you're the Jacksonville Jaguars you have
now had another good uh free agency
period everybody save me a lot of people
at least were very hip on the 2016
Jaguars as I always say if you follow
the trends when everybody's on board
that means they're a year away 2017 is
the Jags years is the Jags year with
this asterisk and a significant one is
Blake Bortles going to be halfway decent
if he is not if there is some legitimate
concern with the new coaching staff and
Tom cin don't they owe it to the fan
base to get one of these guys in there
Jake Cutler or Colin Kaepernick if BL if
Bortles Flames out wouldn't it be nice
to then be able to go with a guy who's a
viable starting quarterback instead I
mean you know Chad Henny ain't that Chad
Henny is not guiding them to the
playoffs if you're a jaguars fan when
you when that happened about a month ago
when they resigned Henny you you had to
be thinking to yourself all right so
you're going all in you're going to give
it Blake another shot with a new
coaching staff okay but at least give
yourself a little better cover so I'm
with you on that like and Jay Cutler or
Kaepernick would definitely if you're a
Jags fan if you if you think that you've
built your defense out out and you have
players on offense that you can make
things happen you got to give yourself a
better safety that than Chad Henny where
ises the psychological aspect of it play
into this with a quarterback we hear
Warren Sapp our old colleague used to
always say there's two people you don't
mess with quarterbacks and kickers on a
team and they're psyche so the Jaguars
bring in Jay Cutler we all play a huge
role in this because it's the it would
be a media circus it would be are is is
Cutler taking over for Bortles Bortles
then has that pressure it same with
Kaepernick almost what what what effect
does that play in a team not doing that
move oh come well I mean I hear the I
understand the question but if your QB
can't handle that then is a little bit
too fragile for to to be a leader of men
I don't put the I don't put the kicker
and quarter I get kickers they're a
different breed but the quarterback
should be able to take a little heat a
little pressure but how many times do we
hear that there can't be a quarterback
competition like why why aren't more no
that's different than saying that it it
messes with their heads when you yank
them series to series or if that's the
the threat that you have out there
that's if Cutler goes down there you
don't think there's a competition
between Jay Cutler and Blake Bortles I
think there is and I think that Jags
fans are owed that opportunity now I
mean that that defense should be
legitimate at this point all right we'll
continue to talk about this all other
pro football matters whatever else is on
the brain of Dan hanzus and you drop us
a line at Rich Eisen show on Twitter
Dave damashek filling in for Rich Eisen
on the rich Rich Eisen show Dave
damashek here filling in for Rich Eisen
show muzzle again and forever to
everyone on the Rich Eisen show Emy
nominees they are seated to my immediate
right award-winning I don't know but uh
much beloved podcast and he's the host
of it the around the NFL podcast
available on iTunes and Beyond it's Dan
hanus and we're kibit in about Pro
football can I just say by the way
congratulations to the Chris's and Rich
uh that that's a big deal nomination we
got our podcast got a Stitcher award in
2013 and our producer uh told the
stitcher people to mail the award to her
home address and we never saw it again
well that's following a grand tradition
cuz we won that very happened we won the
very same Stitcher award the year before
and our producer did the same thing kept
it kept it at his desk can't trust us
producers we outrageous Deeds that's
hilarious yeah all right yeah hilarious
now listen hus let's figure this out
Cutler Kaepernick who do you uh I mean
there are plenty of quarterback
situations out there in the NFL I know
we're several months away from it and
pending the draft there are by by all
accounts by all the scouts our Pals
Daniel Jeremiah Bucky Brooks and Beyond
say that there really isn't a franchise
QB available there maybe the deshan
Watson can be that maybe a couple other
kids out there but I don't think the
answer is sitting there in the draft
necessarily the Browns the Bengals have
worse quarterback situations your jets
do the ners do the
Jags I'm trying to go off the top of my
head here Cincinnati's in a bad
quarterback situation you know the the
word that AJ McCarron can be had for the
right price I kind of think they're
they're looking to deal the wrong QB you
can
reset you can deal the big contract of
Andy Dalton does any I don't understand
when I you know I debate this with
people all the time what am I missing
with with with Andy Dalton versus AJ
McCarron do you really think it's that
big a difference between those two guys
Andy Dalton was one of the best
quarterbacks in the league in 2015 when
he played behind one of one of the two
or three best offensive lines in the
league with AJ Green and A a bounty of
nice pass catchers but AJ McCarron
wouldn't have been one of the top 10
quarterback I I I am not excited about
AJ McCarron I've heard him floated
around I would not
want wanted him to end up on the Jets
maybe he's good maybe it's like the
tattoo situation that throws me off a
little bit with AJ not the guy that you
would think would be covered in ink yeah
this is uh is everyone aware of that is
that common knowledge that if when he
takes off his shirt if you're not ready
for it that torso will drop your jaw AJ
McCarron nice southern guy takes a shirt
off he's covered covered and tats there
was a huge story during the draft of
Kaepernick because some writer somewhere
called Colin Kaepernick I don't want
called him a thug with tattoos written
all over his chest and someone he's like
I would much rather somebody like a
wholesome AJ McCarron with no knowledge
that AJ McCarron is completely Inked Up
all under his chest and it it blew up in
the 2013 draft I want to say 2014 but AJ
McCarren could be like an extra in Sons
of Anarchy they do a reboot it's like
that crazy Google it everybody really
you should Google it of course AJ
McCarron probably best known for all of
his deeds at Alabama being being a point
of reference for Brent musberger during
a uh a college football game of
significance um let's talk about the
running back that's the other big
offseason story it feels like uh so far
in the NFL and that's uh you know Adrien
Peterson's out there Jamal Charles is
out there now there's word Marshon Lynch
is considering a comeback he sat out all
of last year of course might want to
play for the Oakland Raiders first of
all with that do you think if you are a
Raiders fan which which Marshon Lynch is
you're an Bay native now where the
Raiders are leaving your hometown to go
to Vegas does this affect you if you're
Marshon Lynch I think it would have if
they were leaving like next year this
year but he he'll be 34 35 by the time
they actually move to Vegas so although
maybe he's annoyed by it or maybe he'll
take it personally on that level from a
a playing stance it doesn't make a
difference I well but do you you feel
like I'm not going to honor a team that
was disloyal to my hometown F I'll play
for anybody but the Raiders now dude
loves Oakland I know he does dude loves
Oakland but he could go out the last
memory as uh the Oakland Raiders could
be him hoisting a Lombardi trophy I
think I I I think that uh that would
intrigue me enough as as marshan Lynch
that I would want to do that do you buy
that he can come back with the year off
and be effective in the NFL well what is
he 31 now 30 something like that and the
one thing I think people are forgetting
is uh that he didn't look that great the
last time we saw him he he was banged up
he missed about half the year and Thomas
RS outplayed him uh and maybe that was
just a bad year because he was banged up
and and maybe he's fully rejuvenated now
or maybe like he was following the path
of many Veteran running backs that as he
was getting toward 30 he was losing a
step or two and now you take a year off
you're going to expect to get old beast
mode I wouldn't assume that if this ever
happened all of a sudden the Raiders are
set up at running back here's a question
for you h zo send you the Chris's you
have marshan Lynch Adrien Peterson Jamal
Charles or the draft a running back Rich
draft at that which option do you take
if you're the Oakland Raiders or any
other team that needs a running
back I would go after Adrien Peterson I
think if his price tag comes down and
there was he actually addressed it AP
that he's not looking for 8 million a
year let's hope he's not because just a
32-year old running back's not going to
get that type of money but if he ends up
taking a more Team friendly deal I could
see Peterson having another good year
and that and you know a 1200 yard season
or something like that just on the uh
damek podcast earlier this week your pal
Chris wesling from around the NFL came
on and and did remind me legitimately I
needed the reminder it is fascinating
how narratives can take everybody in a
direction we have collectively sort of
Forgotten Adrien Peterson it wasn't very
long ago he just led the league in in
rushing that was a year and a half ago
now he really he really struggled though
last year like he he was averaging what
two 2.4 yard yard per carry the same
thing is remember when he came back from
the knee injury he looked old or I'm
sorry from the suspension I should say
but also though that Vikings offensive
line lost three guys you put Adrien
Peterson behind that Raiders offensive
line I I'm definitely intrigued probably
number two on that list same goes for
Maran Lynch though highly upgraded
offensive line than the one he was
running behind in Seattle do you say a
year off means he's rested well or do
you say he's Rusty it depends which side
of that Marshon Lynch coin you look at
but the Raiders pick 24th overall so
realistically for nette's gone at
probably Joe Mixon Mixon is still there
but mcaffrey might be hanging around
think really with the Mixon stuff and
I'm not getting up on Mount Pas about uh
about whether or not he belongs on an
NFL roster I think you do want to avoid
Joe Mixon if you feel like we're a legit
super Super Bowl Contender you don't
want to bring somebody in there that
could blow up the locker room I don't
know if if a Rookie's misdeeds off the
field are enough to do that but I but I
would I'd be more cautious if I were a
player or two away from the Super Bowl
to bring in somebody who who who could
be volatile to answer your original
question I think aside from quarterback
and maybe the one or two special players
at a specific position everyone is
replaceable so you go with the younger
cheaper player and that's obviously
found in the NFL draft
right it's the inverse of quarterbacks
you want the 10e guy who's got a lot of
experience at quarterback you want you
you don't need that at running back you
want the fresh legs I'd rather have a
22y old who's only getting paid $600,000
it's funny though when you put it into
that context that you would take that
you would take a rookie an unproven
rookie over a guaranteed first ballot
Hall of Famer one of the three or four
best running backs of the Super Bowl ER
it's fun money you could also do both
you get Peterson you have him for a year
if you still got the juice maybe he's a
one or two year option and then you have
the young kid and you could do a little
mix and match with them you signed
Peterson to INX match I get it incentive
L an incentive contract right like yeah
like it will break down to guaranteed
money uh no guaranteed money after year
one I mean I don't know if Peterson has
much leverage anymore so we'll see all
right Dan hanus are you leaving us now I
got to go I got to go record our podcast
he's going to go make his noise on the
around the NFL podcast make sure you
track it down on iTunes as well as end
around on nfl.com hand Zeus's take on
all things pro football the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at no Eastern on
audience